first up he is an environmental activist
and author of the novel Radio Free
Vermont a fable of resistance Bill
McKibben the lion okay so it's fitting
you're here on our last show because
this has been a year where we saw
terrible things happened with the
environmental movement and I was very
dismayed to see last week that the Paris
Accords which were signed two years ago
none of the industrialized countries are
even close to meeting their marks and
they're not mandatory the scariest in a
way was what happened in China where
they've actually been pretty good about
putting in a lot of renewable power last
year their coal went up coal use went up
because they had a wicked drought
california-style drought and they
couldn't run their hydroelectric dams
this is the sort of thing that's
starting to happen the vicious feedback
cycles are starting to kick in the the
we had a record rise three parts per
million in the amount of carbon in the
atmosphere last year and we're afraid
it's because oceans forests have been
damaged to the point where they're no
longer absorbing carbon as quickly as
they used to so we're right on the edge
it's the moment to be moving fast yeah
I've heard that for years we're right on
the edge we got to start moving fast
dependent mean in some ways we're right
over the edge I was in yeah Sonoma last
you know two nights ago talking with
people who come through the FAR's I mean
this is as close as we get to sort of
the definition of the good life in
America beautiful place huge vats of
wine everywhere there's people fleeing
for their lives and lots of them not
making it out that kind of thing
happened someplace on this planet every
day now yeah and you know there's
another conference going on this week in
Bonn Germany and the Trump
administration showed up with a plan for
coal they're trolling the climate
agreement meetings now they got trolled
right back all 400 people who are at the
sitting in the room for this coal
presentation just got up and left
and the craziness of it I mean the rest
of the world's like electric cars solar
batteries whatever the Trump
administration's like we've got some
great 18th century technology that we'd
like you to show you here yeah Rick
Perry wants to subsidize coal and and
maybe whale oil after that I mean when
you think about that that someone did a
study a report a few weeks ago there's
more people in America who work at
Arby's roast beef sandwiches than mine
coal in a rational world we're having
Oval Office summits on sort of roast
beef policy you know I mean the real
jobs the the real thing we should be
subsidizing is Sun and wind which we
desperately need have you ever convinced
a denier have you ever been able to to
take someone aside and just talk to them
calmly and rationally and have them go
wow I see your point
I must have been wrong all these years
this is this is the right question the
week before Thanksgiving my advice would
be don't wreck dinner sort of trying to
argue with your crazy uncle the most
most people the 70% of Americans
understand what's going on the 30% who
don't aren't going to be convinced by
the next you know study of infrared
absorption patterns in the stratosphere
or whatever there believe what they
believe for ideological reasons if you
spent the last thirty years kind of
marinating in Rush Limbaugh you'd be you
know impervious to reason to its and so
I think with I think the
[Music]
the right response is to say we got to
take that 70% and get them active and
engaged in this fight or at least some
part of them if you just can't stand it
at Thanksgiving you know turn to him and
say you may not believe in global
warming but global warming believes in
you right and I want to get your opinion
on the economics of this because I don't
think this has brought up enough that
economics really obviously we know how
it affects the environment and the
argument that it's going to ruin jobs
which is of course not true but it's
also true that the people who are poor
generally don't care about the
environment when you cannot blame them
because they have the the argument is
they have more immediate problems and
they do I'm just making the point that
income inequality very much impacts in
environmental progress as long as people
are living hand-to-mouth they kind of
can't had always heard this right
environmentalism is something that rich
white people do if you didn't know your
next meal was coming from you wouldn't
be right environmentalist when we
started organizing 350.org first thing
we did was this global day of action we
had 5,200 demonstrations in 181
countries people were sending in
pictures from every corner of the planet
it took me about half an hour of
watching those come in on Flickr to
realize that pretty much everybody we
were working with was poor black brown
Asian young because that's what the
world consists of I think you can make a
pretty good argument at this point that
rich white people may represent more of
the environmental problems oh they
definitely use more resource
and they kind of get in the way of
things - I mean you know those rich
white people self-loathing clapping so
let me ask you about this elephant thing
because I saw a great documentary this
year called when Giants fall and you can
google it and you'll see you can see it
on the internet and it's about the
elephants in their plight and Trump he's
kind of hedging on it now but he was
saying yesterday they were going to undo
the Obama rule because we have to undo
everything Obama did of course and that
you couldn't take your trophies from
killed elephant's back here to the
United States what do you think of that
because there actually are some
environmental people what you know this
is this is just I heard on junior
Protection Act you know rubbing back the
bring back the tusks of the thing he
attacked and it goes hand in hand with I
mean he's he's saying we're gonna take a
pause on this one today because there
was so much resistance to it maybe he
could also perhaps pause the new rule
they put into effect earlier this year
that lets you lets hunters shoot
hibernating bears in their dens look I
think there's their sportsmen I think
there's a contest in the White House
every day what's the coolest thing you
can think of and whoever wins gets to
wear the Red Hat for the you know next
day or something it's just it's insane
all right do we have any help though you
keep doing what we've got lots I mean
the hope is in the resistance right it's
gotta start with well that's right and I
saw in Virginia that the resistance is
starting to electoral as you know so
we'll go forward with that under the
thank you for your hero for what you do